foreign
[Music]
the speed run will end when we're 2300.
I do have a plan outlined for after the
speed run
I think I have
found a solution which everybody will
enjoy
as a sneak preview there will be indeed
another speed run I'll continue making
these videos the plan in an idealized
scenario is the following one or two
speed run videos a week
and then heavy emphasis on YouTube only
if it is I really want to push the end
game series and I wanna I wanna do a
series on basically the lives and best
games of a ton of different GMS while
also staying centered on chess
instructions so you've got a lot to look
forward to
let's jump into a speedrun game for now
15 plus 10.
here we go guys black against player
person 20.
okay so 184 yeah well
let's let's play um let's play E5 Let's
uh
let's stick to Our Roots here Knight F3
Knight C6 it's been a while since we
played E5 and we're facing the scotch
we're facing the scotch obviously the
move as he takes D4
and Knight takes D4 this is the pure
Scotch of course as you might know white
also has the scotch Gambit that's Bishop
C4 uh and there's the somewhat obscure
move C3 but Knight takes D4 is the main
line now here uh essentially black has
two moves that are considered to be the
main moves uh obviously they're not the
only two moves in the position they're
not not even the only two viable moves
but these are the two moves that are
responsible for like 90 of top level
games
um one of them is Knight C5 and the move
that I have recommended uh during the
speed run and I've recommended this to
students because I think it's a little
bit less Theory and Knight F6 becomes
incredibly messy if you know anything
about the main line Knight F6 leads to
very chaotic and very interesting
positions but positions that have to be
studied uh exceedingly carefully really
for for both sides in order to play it
well I think Bishop C5 is a little bit
more practical now it's still extremely
theoretical you still have to know a lot
I mean you have to know a lot to play
one E5 but this is a little bit more
manageable I don't know this line all
that well I sort of know the basics of
it
does anybody know what Black's main move
is here
you basically need to put pressure on
the Knight on D4
yeah Queen F6
because the threat the threat was Knight
takes C6 attacking the queen and then
Bishop takes C5
so Queen F6 gets out of the purview of
the White Knight
C3 this is the main continuation and now
we basically develop our pieces we play
the move Knight G to E7
um we are not afraid of Knight takes C6
here
because we can grab the bishop on E3
first threatening mate on F2 that's
partially why we put our Queen on F6
F takes E3 then we recapture on C6 and
obviously we have ruined White's entire
Pawn structure so Knight takes C6 is a
very very bad move here
white has a couple of ways that they can
proceed Bishop E2 Bishop C4 I think is
the most popular move Bishop C4 is on
the board
and um
okay well we obviously continue our
development Bishop C4 doesn't change
anything about that so let's Castle
playing pretty quickly thus far but
nothing to write home about one subtlety
we should point out is that if white
plays Knight takes C6 here
our response has changed we can no
longer take on E3 because the Knight
would have taken 97 with check so there
we would have just taken back with the
queen black is still completely fine now
the move is indeed Knight E5 as many of
you are pointing out the drawback of
developing the bishop to C4 is that it
is a vulnerable piece what is it
vulnerable to well it's vulnerable to
the centralizing move 95 as far as I
remember 95 is like the move that is
supposed to yield uh the simplest
equality I also know or I actually seem
to remember that uh Victor bolagon who
is a grand master originally from
Moldavia he wrote a book on one E5 and I
want to say that he recommends B6 here
uh but I'm not totally positive now D6
would be a serious mistake D6 is a very
tempting move
who can tell me why D6
isn't good it doesn't blunder anything
but it it is a serious positional
mistake it cuts off the queen from the
Knight which means that white can play
Knight takes C6 now again we can't take
on E3 because the Knight takes 97 with
check but after D6 Knight takes C6
Knight takes C6 white trades on C5
completely ruining Black's Queen Side
Pawn structure and giving white a major
Dynamic Plus in the center I want to
play bullet guns recommendation here
let's play the move B6 this will
hopefully take our opponent out of Fury
95 is very theoretical and I don't
remember it that well there's 95 and D5
but I don't remember exactly how to
handle that position so we're gonna go
with what I know is Victor bolagon's
recommendation in his book which is a
move that looks very weird but if you
really think about it it shouldn't be
that weird we want to develop the bishop
but as we just discussed the move D6 is
a serious position and accuracy so we're
circumventing the problem uh aiming for
the fianchetto without really ruining
our pod structure and most importantly
if Knight takes C6 we preserve the
ability to recapture with the queen on
C6 supporting the bishop on C5
and also it doesn't hurt it most
certainly doesn't hurt that the bishop
is now anchored by the pawn so this
becomes a little bit less of a headache
in general maybe in the future when the
queen is no longer on F6
uh this is all I know by the way B6 is
basically all I know so we're basically
on our own here
I just said the word basically like
seven times and I have no idea why
but in any case our opponent is finally
thinking
F4 okay
I seem to remember that this is the main
move
now let's think
let's try to understand what our options
are
um and let's weigh
the pros and cons of those options so I
feel like the default option is to play
Bishop E7
right I don't see what F4 threatens
exactly a lot of you might be concerned
about the movie five but remember that
if there is a bishop on B7 the movie 5
comes with a hefty price tag it opens up
the long diagonal for our Bishop Our
Queen could potentially slide to G6
already creating tons of threats against
G2 although if you calculate a little
bit further Bishop B7 E5 Queen G6 there
is the Annoying move F5 so maybe it's
more prudent after Bishop b75 to tuck
the queen away on H6 there white cannot
play F5 because the bishop on E3 hangs
so that seems like one viable option
um there's others we could maybe even
consider the move D5 here after the game
I'll I'll show you why D5 is a tempting
move for me as well
but for the purposes of this game let's
be efficient and let's be
straightforward with our developing move
Bishop B7 okay maybe this is a mistake
but
you know it is what it is I think it
can't be that bad you know what I'm
saying
I mean you're just developing your
pieces how terrible can that be
it looks scary but not really it doesn't
really look all that scary to me why
because we don't have any Targets right
what you might be seeing is you might be
saying well this this looks scary
White's playing E5 is going to blow us
off the board that's not how chess works
you actually have to have targets and
weaknesses for your opponent to blow you
off the board let's go Queen H6 as we
discussed here yeah these pawns look
intimidating but they're also kind of
stuck in molasses and we have a hidden
threat one of the draws of Queen H6 is
that it sets a hidden threat that's so
easy to miss who can spot it
who can spot the threat
yeah Knight takes C5 very good remember
that an x-ray works both ways when you
look at this extra you might say that's
bad for the queen because The Bishop's
X-ray and the queen well two can play at
that game the queen is also x-raying the
bishop the bishop happens to be uh L uh
undefended type one it's not defended by
anything so Knight takes E5 is a threat
another
uh downside of the move F4 for white is
that any time we take on E3 now it's
going to be a check which potentially is
important once again in variations where
white wants to consider taking on C6 the
move I'm expecting from our opponent the
move that might be the reason Bishop B7
is wrong if it's wrong
is probably Queen D2
defending the bishop and setting up the
move F5 which if it is played I
confess is quite a scary Prospect
um no a night sack on E5 on the previous
move
we can talk about this after the game
but it's way premature well it just
takes the Knight and plays Bishop F4 and
the quote-unquote initiative is repelled
before it even gets off the ground
yeah our opponent taking taking uh his
sweet time his or her sweet time
now I have an idea against Queen D2
I'm not I'm not thrilled with that idea
but I feel like it's
I mean at least it stops at five
Queen E2 okay this one I didn't entirely
expect but it makes a lot of sense it
still defends against
the bishop and it actually opens up the
D2 Square for the Knight so it's a very
smart move
okay
so time to introduce my idea
basically
to use that word again
the battle here rages over control of
the F5 square right if black can control
the F5 Square then we freeze White's
King Side Pawn play which is quite a
significant asset for us how do we
engineer that situation well in order to
control F5 we need to eliminate the
Knight what do we take the Knight with
well taking with the Knight makes
absolutely no sense why it takes back
with a pawn and the bishop is actually
trapped in that resulting position
Bishop before A3 so we have to give up
our dark Spirit Bishop that's a big
quote unquote sacrifice but in return we
get the F5 Square
and white is potentially saddled with
these pawns which could be a strength
but could also end up being a weakness
I think our position is quite tolerable
here probably not great but very much
tolerable and if white plays D5 then
again that falls falls for Knight 65. I
feel like a lot of people here a lot of
good players would play D5 kind of
automatically let's push the Knight away
any time a pawn is pushed you have to
evaluate the impact it has on other
pawns on the way stuff is defended
you have to reassess the tactics which
previously didn't work
which is why in such positions I'm going
to make a bunch of mental notes to
myself and one of them is always check
for Knight takes C5 we knew that it was
an idea here
right so this is where I made that
mental note check for Knight takes C5 in
every position
which is what allows me to see this move
in the event of D5
and you want to make these mental notes
to yourself throughout the game like if
you see a potential tactical pattern
what people don't understand is doesn't
have to work in the present position you
can still mentally note the pattern to
yourself and then it decreases the
possibility that you're going to miss it
later on down the line when it actually
does work
that's a lot of talk but hopefully that
point is well taken
with Landing says white has two Bishops
and black has no obvious compensation
not totally true our compensation comes
in the form of our light Square control
right you don't have to have
compensation for the two but the two the
bishop pair isn't an advantage to the
point where like it's automatically good
like an extra it's not an inherently
good thing it's good most of the time
but it's not something that we should
really do like cry over
might C3
hmm
I don't understand this move
can't we
snag the pawn on D4 am I missing
something
no we're not missing anything Knight C
takes D4 notice that I took with the c
Knight so that the other night would
stay to pressure the bishop
yeah our opponent losing the thread
there a little bit we want to quit an
important Central Pawn
and the bonus of this move is that we
can support our night with the move C5
but here we should
we should take our time because remember
that once your opponent blunders
something small chances are that that's
going to be followed by an even bigger
blunder you know that that happens
mistakes come in pairs as they do here
Queen D2 is just total Collapse by our
opponent right so you say okay you have
the C2 Square for the Knight and if you
play Knight takes C3 then it's a
situation where both Knights are
threatening to jump to C2 and white
cannot capture both Knights at the same
time so Knight takes E3 is an easy win
and we win a ton of material yeah Queen
takes C3 and
unless I'm missing something yeah just
Knight C2
just Knight C2 easy clap and All That
Remains after we win The Exchange
okay I'm just making notice that I'm not
playing instantly I'm making sure that
there's no like crazy attacking options
there are none we take the exchange
now the game isn't totally over white
still has pretty active minor pieces so
you should never assume that okay the
game is over you can do whatever you
want you still want to be as accurate as
possible
people saying white has made in six yeah
you know probably our opponent is
considering the move F5
which is no longer scary at all because
our Queen is now a perfect perfectly
placed Defender
so
if you're
you know if you want to take an active
role in your opponent's turn start
thinking about what we're gonna do after
Rook takes A1 what is Black's top
priority how do we how do we
um
not accelerate but how do we make as
efficient as possible the winning the
winning process
well Queen G6 White's not going to yield
right if you play Queen G6 White's gonna
drop the queen back to F2
and that's going to reinforce the threat
of F5 I perfectly like the placement of
the queen on H6 it's out of the way
it's out of the way the queen is not
vulnerable and it's putting pressure on
F4 it can jump to G6 at any moment
yeah D6 right D6 is a very professional
move
because when you're up in exchange you
want to open files
and if we can open the DNE files what
black basically wins the game
so I don't know what it is with me in
this word today but
okay D6
yeah D6 is simple and strong
King h8 is unnecessary because G7 is not
under attack or under any kind of
pressure
the easiest is to play D6 this forces at
least one file open
says weak isolated D6 pawn and you'll as
well remember after e takes D6 we're
going to take back with a queen that's
what the queen is for
oh no definitely take back with the
queen of course no take back with the
queen control the D file okay rookie one
I think a lot of people here would
hesitate to take on E5 and rightly so
right you shouldn't take on E5
immediately because it lets the white
Rook become active
so
let's see what
options are at our disposal well we can
definitely play the move Rook ae8 first
but remember that I have to Rook a to E8
we want to take on E5 on the next move
White's gonna play F takes E5 and it
kind of keeps the center relatively
close ideally we would want to get rid
of this Pawn
ideally we would want to get rid of the
spawn so what I'm going to do is
actually still play D take C5
and I hope that our opponent takes back
with a rook which he does because this
will allow me to show that this is a
phantom threat it looks annoying that
Rook on E5 but it has no inherent value
it's not threatening anything Our Queen
is protecting all of the weak spots on
the king side
and all we have to do here is basically
yeah it's like a it's like a tick at
this point uh is I don't know if I say
that word
as regularly in like regular you know in
in most streams I don't know what it is
today and that you know and that word
it's just basically inexplicable so what
should we do we go rookie yeah I think
I'm just tired we go Rook ae8 we offer
The Rook trade and we say okay you have
an ultimatum either you trade Rooks or
you move your Rook away from the e-file
giving us control of the open file why
did I put that Rook on the eight and not
the other one because I want the other
one to be reinforcing the pawn and F7
just in case just in case
okay
well
now I'm not satisfied with the placement
of our Queen
I'm not satisfied with the placement
organ the queen could be doing a lot
more
now what does it need to be doing well
it must defend G7 which limits the
options to one
but this placement is so much better
because we're threatening Queen D4 check
and we're Paving the way for the move H6
which is going to chase The Rook away
from G5 and give us a little bit more
breathing room
H6 Queen D4 Rook E3
we put our pieces on good squares Bishop
D3
okay there there there yeah now I think
we have a force to win
we we have several forced ones actually
we can start with the move
well what should we do
no need to no need to be defensive check
get on with the business right Queen D4
check rookie three game over
unless yeah King H1
there are several ways to end the game
even even Queen takes D3 if you want to
be pretty and you want to be accurate
play Queen takes D3 because Rook takes
G7 check looks scary
but when you're at this level you just
can't look at a move and say oh this
looks scary I'm going to stop
calculating right
no move has inherent like a move being
scary is not a legitimate reason uh to
not go into it because after Queen takes
D3 Rook takes G7 King h8 white has no
more checks Rook GA Rook H7 both are
meaningless and if white takes the queen
then rookie one is game over otherwise
we basically Force the queen trade
that was that was deliberate
foreign
basically one
it's a reason Tom ladies and gentlemen
it is resign time for white
and your mouth slips all right that'll
do it Queen F1 is checkmate
another one in the can let's
take a quick look at it this was a
relatively short relatively simple game
uh but nonetheless plenty to talk about
plenty of instructive lessons to take
away and I think that's the attitude
that you should always have right no
matter what game you play there's
something that can be learned from it
there's no such thing as a game that can
be learned from
so the scotch is still very very popular
Gary Kasparov was largely responsible
for the scotch being a popular opening
at the top level in the 90s he was
essentially the only
top player who played the scotch
regularly
and for a very long time the sort of
theoretical dispute
consisted in the line Knight F6
here white plays Knight takes c66 of
course Knight C3 is the four Knight
Scotch which is a significantly quieter
opening
but the the crazy line goes Knight C6 PC
white goes E5
does anybody know what the mainline
theory is Knight D5 here is hint hint
not the main move
there's a there's a cool little sequence
here yeah Queen E7 Queen E2 now black
plays Knight D5 white plays C4 and
another one of those moves now which you
you wouldn't really think of unless you
know the theory and that's Bishop C8 to
A6 this is like the starting point for a
crazy amount of scotch Theory by the way
Knight B6 here I have analyzed and it's
a sideline but I actually think that it
might be the simplest way to equalize
Knight B6 and then quickly pushing the
d-pawn so the reason I don't really
recommend this line to beginners and
intermediate players is because it's
like very heavy on Theory and not at all
heavy on Concepts you just get like a
super irrational position and you know
there's all these like weird moves and
weird Maneuvers and I just don't feel
like it's a great way uh to to test your
knowledge of Concepts it's more about
memorization if you're if you're good
with that then by all means you can look
up this line and you can win a bunch of
games with black here
but that's why my recommendation is a
far more uh straightforward line which
is Bishop C5
so here white has three main lines
you'll remember that xqc against Charlie
went C3 Queen F6
but the three main lines are Knight
takes C6
to which black normally responds Queen
F6 we've had a game like this
there is Bishop B3 which happened in the
game and there's Knight B3 uh which was
popularized uh sort of a couple of years
ago I think actually this is where the
main theoretical dispute lies these days
Bishop B6 Knight C3 Knight F6 white
Place Bishop G5 there was an mvl Carlson
game about six seven years ago I think
in the same sinkfield cup where caruana
went off there was a game in the slide
and Carlson knew everything already back
then
and indented in a draw
anyways Bishop B3 is the most popular
move I think
Queen F6
and as I was explaining Knight takes C6
we played Bishop to xc3 notice that this
is the idea of putting the queen on F6
apart from putting pressure on the
Knight
F take C3 D takes C6 black is doing
amazing
um so Queen F6 C3 Knight G7 developing
Bishop C4 Main Line castles castles and
yeah checking opening Explorer
it says that the most popular move is
Bishop B6 which I didn't know 95 is also
popular Bishop E2 and now Queen G6
with the idea that if white plays F4
you can actually take on e4 and attack
the bishop
you can attack the bishop here
so this would be a blunder Knight D2 D5
is the main line this is what I was
struggling to remember and then there's
this move
things get things get really heated here
it's like position gets incredibly
complicated
so you have to know this by heart which
is why I decided uh not to involve
myself with this and play B6
so F4 is a move
and here indeed I did not make the main
yeah I mentioned does anybody remember
what move I mentioned during the game as
something that I would consider in a
classical game what is that move
that I mentioned because we play Bishop
B7 which is uncommon D5 yeah so what the
heck is D5 like doesn't that just
blunder upon
well if you look more carefully after e
takes D5
black has not one but two viable options
the first which is what I had in mind is
Knight takes D4
is Knight takes D4
um and this is the game yeah Vladimir
Georgie have had this with black so a
strong player
or even Bishop D6 and look at how
terrible White's pawns are this seems to
be enough compensation
so after Ed 94 if Bishop D4 you take on
D4 you trade queens and I calculated up
until this point I feel like the D5 Pawn
is going to be lost and it's
approximately equal maybe black is a
tiny bit better
um
but I decided not to play D5 because it
took a lot of the life out of the
position you know it led to a bunch of
Trades
so we decided on Bishop B7
E5 Queen H6 I see one game
in this position in the database that is
the game
oh music stefanova
music against Antoinette Stefano one of
the former I think women's number two uh
so there's a high level game in this
position
and that game went Queen D2 the
stefanova game when Queen D2 black talk
Black Blade Knight F5 select exactly as
we did and here why I played Knight C3
so I actually think that Queen E2 is an
inaccuracy precisely because after takes
takes Knight F5 black gains a Tempo on
the D4 Pawn black gains a Tempo on the
D4 Pawn
and what does that Tempo give us well it
gives us an opportunity to stabilize the
Knight on F5 consolidate the situation
if White had played Queen D2 We would
have done the same thing Bishop D4 CD
Knight F5 but here white can safely
develop her Knight Knight C3
the game continued Knight C7
and here Maria music played D5 former
women's world champion
and it looks like white is better
stefanova played D6 Rook ae1
takes takes d e f e I mean look at these
pawns this looks real scary
Rook D3 they went into an end game
and eventually Maria musi took one so I
would be interested in checking the
evaluation within it with an engine but
I have a feeling that white is better
after Queen D2
note that at this level this is what the
game boils now to these subtleties
placement of the queen on one square
rather than another
right small differences in the way that
you develop your pieces that's what
decides the outcome of the game at a
2000 plus level
Knight C3 of course is a inexcusable
blunder at this level that is a very
very bad move what should white have
done instead probably Rook D1
again if D5 then Knight takes C5
fe5 and queen takes E3 check yeah so
this is what we're speculating but Rook
D1 I think white is doing okay we
probably would have played stefanova's
move Knight C7 Knight C3 so you get a
similar position but the queen on E2 is
somewhat inferior to the queen on D2
um
but yeah Knight C3 is very
anti-climactic I mean white just
collapses instantly even here at least
take on D4 and go Queen F2
but you can see very clearly
and we by the way would have probably
gone C5 to protect the Knight how
quickly people collapse right you miss a
move boom Another blunder Knight takes
E3
and Knight C2 on the game is over like
it just took three moves from the moment
the white started collapsing for us to
win the game D6 and D takes C5 followed
by Roque E8 not fearing ghosts if
something is defended then it is
defended Queen F6
heading for D4 preparing H6 24 and a
nice little flourished and the game
white mouse slip but Rook G7 King h8 is
game over anyway yeah The Rook G of Rook
takes G8 Rook H7 Queen H7
in either case white is down a million
pieces
is G4 ask rescue meerkat ever a move for
white here while you have a knight in F5
great question so let's rewind a little
bit
is G4 ever removed so hypothetically of
course it is right the answer to the
question is it ever a move is generally
going to be yes it's generally I can
design a situation such that G4 is going
to be a good move is it going to be good
the majority of the time no because it's
extremely weakening obviously playing it
here is a terrible idea because you
still give up the D4 upon this move
occurs with tempo after Rook D1 Knight
C7 G4 looks better than it did on the
previous move but I still don't like it
because for example look at how weak
your king side pawns are you have bitten
off more than you could chew
and for example a simple move that black
and make here that could cause annoyance
is something like Knight G6 piling up on
the F4 Pawn you could hopefully
everybody can see that white looks like
he's overextended maybe not but this
isn't very very pleasant oh and queen C6
excellent oh excellent catch Queen C6
actually looks even better for black
you're just infiltrating G2 or H1
with Tempo means with a with a threat
basically
so
the the most likely situation in which
G4 would be a good move is probably one
in which white keeps the dark scored
bishop or maybe has a Pawn on D5 But to
answer your question yes it's something
to be considered of course all right
guys I think this gives us a good
opportunity to round off the stream for
tonight
hope you enjoyed the show I'm gonna head
to bed
let's do it guys thank you for hanging
out and I will see y'all tomorrow
foreign
[Music]